welcome everyone to LED live we are
excited because on this episode we're
gonna talk about Christ in the context
of culture and what are we gonna be
looking at today we're gonna be looking
at on word which is set to drop in about
a week is on words something to
Christians should be watching find out
now find out on this episode of LED live
[Music]
first of all we want to thank our
patrons you guys are a big help to our
show you're the ones that help keep this
content free and we want to thank you
for that we're up to how many supporters
now guys 220 to you could be 223 if you
sign up so we encourage you to check us
out on patreon and sign up we have a lot
of perks on there for different donor
levels so help keep the content flowing
for everyone also after this show we
have a special perk for our patrons we
have a patreon post show discussion so
look for that after this episode is over
and we have a tendency to drop those
early so it's just a perk of being a
donor what level do they get that at is
it five dollars a month so as little as
five dollars a month you could be
checking out these extra discussions
that we've put out after our shows we
also want to let you know about our
merch we've got t-shirts like the one
I'm wearing right now it says pray for
your haters remember the Sabbath I'm
awesome and you can find those on
teespring you can see the link on the
screen more than just t-shirts that we
have DVDs and for this particular show
we want to highlight one DVD in
particular this is a documentary we made
several years ago it's called Magic
Kingdom what does your heart tell you to
follow and this is gonna cover some of
the topics that they teach little kids
and is all of that good is it something
that Christians should be taking in what
are those messages you can find out in
this documentary so we encourage you to
check it out on our store a little light
Studios TV towards the lash shop or if
you prefer the higher quality digital
downloads like some of us I don't buy
any DVD more
I can't remember the last time I bought
a DVD we have Vimeo and on Vimeo you can
rent or you can buy you can rent for as
little as $2.99 sometimes $0.99 we're
having a sale
or you can buy for documentaries
generally $9.99 or sometimes less if
we're having a sale so check us out on
Vimeo we have digital downloads so today
everyone we're gonna talk about Pixar's
latest film which is set to drop in
about a week from today
hmm it is called onward have you heard
of onboard heard it heard of it what
have you heard some about them bringing
their dad back from the dead okay okay
anything else they they play a lot of
rock and roll the 80s are great yeah
okay well I want to show you the trailer
and we will jump right into this but
this episode is about onward oh oh it's
magic all right it's always magic it
seems like in yeah so let's check out
the trailer now
happy birthday mr. adult man gross what
was dad like this beard was Scratchy
he had a goofy laugh I wish I'd bet him
I have something for you Sami your dad
it's a wizard staff
I wrote this spell so I could see for
myself who my boys grow up to be
the spell brings him back back away back
to life he wanted to beat you more than
anything
dad Oh stow dropped out dad you are in
your house
we've only got 24 hours to bring back
the rest of dad going on a quest Oh
[Music]
quests start with the magical the
fearless adventurer you mean Cory she's
over there that's the manticore getting
the vehicle on escorting yo I'm giving
you to the count of three okay wait what
did you do it I don't know I'm looking
for oh they went on a question but don't
worry I told him about the map I told
him about the gym I've told him about
the curse
[Music]
[Applause]
how are you boys doing a crazy
[Music]
I can't do it we're not gonna see you
dad you can do this I've seen in you
[Music]
my gut knows where to go don't you boy
guru
on my way boys
[Music]
pretty disturbing disturbing in what way
I mean this is necromancy right they're
bringing their dad back from the dead
and we know that biblically the only
person who can do that is Jesus Christ
but they're using spells to do it
but it's got this really epic feel-good
family you know they just want to see
dad leave it's a fixed R to have some
heart-wrenching story the only magic is
family it says what I think it's
interesting when you watch trailers like
this there's a lot of times I'll pop
words on the screen for a brief seconds
and then they'll play a few clips and
then they'll play some more words and
it's like unless you slow everything
down it's hard to figure out maybe what
that is or do you remember even mm-hmm
so it asked a couple of questions one
was how far would you go and what was
the second part of that question for one
more day together how far would you go
for one more day together and the
implication at least that I see in that
is would you practice magic to bring
your loved ones back to life now that
kind of makes me think of movies like
ghosts remember that lady just wanted to
see your husband again and yeah baby
yeah anymore yeah interesting that
they're like outlaws sort of on the run
like like like they're almost like
letting you know this is not good cops
are after me yeah but they're gonna do
it anyway you know yeah there's that
rebellious element there's another
another phrasing here that I caught too
and that was discover your power whoo
right and then it followed it with make
some mess mm-hmm your power making some
magic we talked about magic before magic
is very self driven today you're the one
with the power you're the one that does
all these things which is what draws
people to it they want that power you
know they desire to be in control of
something yeah
which is basically a counterfeit for God
because God is saying listen if you
surrender your life to me the most
powerful being in the universe you will
have access to that and so it's like
this is sort of sidestepping that and
saying
you know what I can gain that power
without you it's forgetting that without
him we are nothing there we don't have
any power with and within ourselves very
well I took a look at what the
dictionary defines magic as this is from
merriam-webster it gives a couple of
definitions it says one the use of means
such as charms or spells believed to
have supernatural power over natural
forces another one was magic rights or
incantations definition two says an
extraordinary power or influence
seemingly from a supernatural source
that was an interesting way to put it or
something that seems to cast a spell
also known as an enchantment or of
course we know that the art of producing
illusions of my sleight of hand what we
typically a lot of times think of it as
magic when I was a little kid I was
fascinated with you know books I
probably shouldn't be reading in the
library and one of those was like card
tricks and stuff you know magic how do
they do these kind of things yeah
interesting though that it magic isn't
often associated with this spell right
to spell something to use language to
put something on somebody right that
that that I see is a counterfeit of
prayer I mean pray you use words and
something supernatural happens when you
pray Bible says that there's a lot of
power in words and that your tongue can
you know it's like a sword that can just
like really hurt somebody and destroy or
build up yeah that's his life and death
are in the power of the tongues right
there's a very powerful thought all
right so I snagged this from Disney's
website here has got a little picture
with a description of what these guys
are trying to do says in Disney and
Pixar's onward brothers ian and barley
Lightfoot tells that they're voiced by
Tom Holland and Chris Pratt are given a
special gift from their late father on
Ian's 16th birthday right almost like
it's getting a car but when an
accompanying spell meant to magically
convert conjure their dad for one day
goes awry they embark on a quest fraught
with some of the most unexpected
obstacles so I thought you know this is
interesting but language that they're
using in that in the little
title here was conjuring that what does
it mean to conjure well the dictionary
says it means to call upon a spirit or a
ghost to appear by means of a magic
ritual oh wow lovely want your
children's involved yeah exactly and if
you watch the trailer closely you would
have noticed that it comes with this
spell to do that which is called the
visitation spell and here you can see
you know you've got part of dad and then
the next part of dad and then all of dad
when you're done so wait this is a
screenshot of what the book is that he's
doing in the trailer yeah this is a
screenshot from the trailer right it's
crazy to me that I mean you get you
gotta just think about this this is kids
stuff
yes Pixar has a wide range of people
that will enjoy this there'll be adults
that will go to this but think of all
the little little kids that go to this
and the first exposure to this kind of
material is like wow you can you can
actually have spells on people you know
I can talk to your dead relatives yeah
this is like leading you to Ouija boards
and things you know this is the stuff
that I was dabbling in when I was a
teenager because of you know the way
movies made it look and the kids may not
be saying the spells but the act of
watching it is an act of participating
and I'll never forget what Eric Wilson
said in our was in the Holy Yoga led
live
he said ignorant does not stop things
from working the way they're supposed to
so if there's spells being said and
spiritualism and magic happening in
these films and we're exposing ourselves
to that
yeah the spirits are definitely gonna
say okay you're opening the door I would
come in and when the kids repeat those
one thing that we brought up in Magic
Kingdom the documentary was the concept
that in Pocahontas remember they use a
lot of like like when she's talking to
the tree and the tree says you know
listen to the spirits they're all around
you and then she just starts singing a
song and she says like Oh Coco Coco
woman brother I don't remember what it
was but but it was not a language that
any of us understand and I actually ran
into someone who was part of the Wiccan
religion
and had converted out of that into
Christianity and she had seen one of our
projects and said oh yeah they have
which incantations and cartoons all the
time so that's crazy to think if you're
sitting there watching something and
there is some sort of real incantation
or spell like like like what you said
with Eric Wilson you know it doesn't
stop it from from working on you if
you're ignorant Lee like don't
understand it I don't think people give
creators enough credit like these people
do intensive research on this stuff
right exactly well we we found out in
the house that they said that they're
you know creative room was just full of
witchcraft books they were open about it
they're they want to make it seem as
real as possible all right so here's
another one that they put up this that
you can find these on Disney and Pixar's
a website
this one's titled in route it says these
brothers ian and barley seek an ancient
map from the manticore once a fearless
warrior whose Tavern served as a way
station for travelers embarking on epic
quests part lion part bat part scorpion
the manticore has adapted to changing
times but her adventurous spirit still
lurks within what I think is interesting
is if you look at this Manticore they've
already given you the gender but if you
didn't know the gender of the manticore
what would you suspect it's a female you
would suspect it was female
right off the bat you mean from the
description or from the furniture from
the image from the image it sounded like
a female it did say but if you didn't
have that if you just had the image what
would you suspect a male yeah it does
why there's a dress tonight male clothes
it's got like a yeah
brutes eyes kind of more shaped like a
male who to me visually the only Q is
the manticore is wearing red high heels
yeah it's like otherwise this one's body
and time fell fast I agree you should if
you were to show us this before the
trailer I think we would have been
saying it's a guy yeah yeah that's very
manly features for an animal
it's not a human is it no but their
person wearing clothes yes that's true a
lot of animals you can't tell much you
look yes
yeah I probably should pull in some more
screenshots but anyway this strikes me
as a very manly creature until I you
know it looks like beasts from beating
the bees yeah it does it looks like a
beast from beating the beasts but as a
female character now I noticed something
on there you said that this the
manticore thing changes times changed
with the times okay yeah it's changed
with the times now here's where I'm
going with this Corey ray is a Pixar
producer for this film she's been
working on this film for six years
okay and one thing that's kind of
striking to me is if you look at Cory
Ray's personal life which you can find
this information on Wikipedia it says
that she's married to another Pixar
producer who is a female hmm and from
watching interviews of her and when she
talks about this film she's like very
particularly excited about the manticore
and I don't find it surprising that the
character appears to blur gender roles
and even more when you look at the book
that's being produced for this film you
can find these books on Amazon this is
called onward tale of the manticore and
it's written by this Marika Tamaki and
she was awarded the honor of distinction
by the Dane Olga V Prize a literary
award for lesbian gay bisexual or
transgender writers in Canada in 2012
now the thing that's striking to me
about that is I didn't have to dig that
up that was in the Amazon description
right before the book and so it's like
they're putting it out there and
highlighting it and it's specifically
about the manticore so I'm like you know
it's kind of odd to me that this
character is all dressed you know very
manly and has this gruff nature no
that's like you're looking up a kids
book on Amazon and that's what they tell
you straight up I'm just trying to find
a kids book you know I wouldn't buy this
but and you get all these you know
details about her sexual life or order
yeah it is is it is odd and it gets even
more odd I think as we go along other
books that you can find for kids about
this film we'll get into that in a
little bit so the manticore
what is the manticore and I looked this
up for on encyclopedia Birkin Britannica
and basically a Manticore is this
creature like the described has the the
body of a lion and tail of a dragon or a
scorpion the head of a man and then it
had this interesting piece it said
medieval writers use the manticore as a
symbol of the devil so in essence it's
the devil that sets them on their quest
to get their dad for another day yeah it
is crazy and so you can find that map
it's actually in the tavern when you
look and as we blow that up it's on the
wall of adventure and you can see there
there's this map for when you go looking
for the Phoenix gem okay and so there's
another book you can also find this on
Amazon it's called in search of the
Phoenix gem and in questa Gatien so what
exactly is the Phoenix gem and why is it
that they need it why they need it is it
I thought was kind of hard to find out I
didn't find any details about the movie
but I did find something about the
Phoenix gem on another website just to
clarify they need the gem for the staff
to work I think Jim yeah I think they
need it to help finish bringing their
dad back there wasn't a lot of detail
like that all I know is they're
searching for it but then like how that
fits the exact storyline I don't know I
mean the whole thing's has not released
yet so it's a little hard to tell okay
but there's this website I came across
called LexA cannon and they talked about
the Phoenix gem it was like the only
place I could find where they're talking
about the Phoenix gem so I'm guessing
this is the inspiration for their source
here's what it says the Phoenix gem is
an elder artifact at the height of the
war in heaven he as Sri Yan himself was
laid low by the
chill blades of his foes now sir yon is
the Phoenix King or he's like the chief
of the Elder Gods and it goes on to say
you know describes him being brought
back to life and then it says even now
it can still return life to the Fallen
so that's why they need it to bring back
their dead dead
that is what I'm guessing it is this
makes it being used to help restore life
so kind of an interesting description oh
that's the only thing I could find on
the internet about what a Phoenix Jim
was interesting and the phoenix rising
from the ashes in a very occultic you
know like regeneration bringing back
something new I was thinking about that
too yep
so what else can you get on Amazon well
when I was looking up some of these
other books this one came up and you can
get this book called onward the wizard
in you hmm what does this book have it
has spell card there are actually 12
spell cards inside now the book has not
been released yet so you can't actually
even get a preview of what these spell
cards look alike do this is like it's
just getting so much you know we've been
building up to this we had Pokemon cars
and all these things they make these
things like innocent to the point where
now it's like yeah let's get some spell
cards for the kids yeah
now in the film I mean yeah at least in
the trailer I did catch this screenshot
where they're practicing this growth
spell does we have a full tank doesn't
work growth spell we grow the can and
then the gas inside will grow with it
[Music]
oh they're actually true they run out of
gas and so then they're trying to get
more gas and so they figure okay well
there's a little bit left in our can so
if we use a growth spell on a gas can
it'll grow the can and grow the gas
inside of the can well the whole thing
goes wrong but this is what this is a
screen capture for the growth spell that
they actually have in the book it looks
like they have some guidelines on how a
die like I like some dice like and if
you look at Barley's vest he has what
looks like a D&D dice on there and
notice and so there's all these
parameters on if the die comes up to
this value you can grow the can like
this move in proportion so there's a
little bit of that going on so it was an
argument presented after the My Little
Pony video that these shows are just a
display of magic they're not teaching
magic they're not they're not teaching a
child exactly how to perform magical
spells and all these things and I found
that interesting because if you okay
even if we were to say okay agreed fine
they're not teaching but then you have
these books you have these cards the
board games all these things books these
subliminal messages like okay if I want
to do this I need to get a book and of
course what does a book have
step-by-step instruction just like a
progression they say the real teaching
of magical arts does not come from the
Harry Potter movies it actually comes
from the Harry Potter books and so mmm
any kid I mean if they're really into
the movies they're gonna be more likely
enticed to read the books and I think in
this same situation here it's like you
know as a little kid this is like
colorful and fanciful and it's like you
know kids dive into it they buy all the
toys and then you know the book so I
could read the stories and and so yeah
maybe everybody is not gonna fall trap
to this watch the movie and then want to
go out and commit spells and things on
people but there are a large amount of
people that that's how this works it's
like planting little seeds and then
those
kids will grow up and get involved in
I'm gonna make a prediction
you're probably gonna make a boardgame
out of this considering you have dice to
roll to make the spill maybe you got the
spill cars you got your dice let's play
onward family let's and then it's gonna
come with a little magnifying glass this
goes over yes or no what are you saying
yeah it's it's pretty creepy
well that's about as far as I'm gonna
take all of this information and I want
to talk about a little bit about what
the Bible has to say about that because
the Bible has some strong language on
magic and practicing magic and doing
spells says in Leviticus 19 26 it says
you shall not eat anything with the
blood neither shall you use enchantment
or observe times and if you think back
to the dictionary definition that we had
from merriam-webster it actually used
the word enchantment yeah right so it
says do not use enchantment just very
plain no if ands or buts there I also
found this in Micah 5:12 it says this is
God talking to the children of Israel
and talking about what he's gonna do in
their nation and I will cut off which
crass out of thine hand and thou shalt
have no more soothsayers clearly God is
looking at this nation of Israel his
chosen people insane uh-uh this is not
gonna be a part of my nation I'm gonna
get rid of this because it's not
supposed to be there I also make sure
worried about our nation's I also
guarantee that if you had a window back
into Israel you could see that all the
Israelites were doing was just observing
how the others worshiped right and then
very easily they were enticed into those
practices so I think you know this is
the same sort of thing like to go back
and and re answer what you're doing - I
think just observing and watching is
going to ultimately lead you down a path
and God has clear language I mean you
read the Old Testament you read the New
Testament same sort of thing like
witchcraft sorcery magic all that stuff
like God will cut you off yeah and it's
true God does offer a hedge of
protection but if you continually put
yourself in that position
and you decide no I'm going to sit and
observe this he's gonna respect your
decision and kind of back off and that
that way the devil has full rein over
that person we also have the story in
the Bible of the king of Israel Manasseh
Manasseh and he had an interesting life
he came to be King at about twelve I
think it was and he reigned for longer
than any other Israelite King if I
remember right it was like fifty five
years I mean he ran for a long time but
the Bible says this about Manasseh it
says also he caused his sons to pass
through the fire fire in the valley of
the son of Hinnom he practiced soot
Shane used witchcraft and sorcery and
consulted mediums and spiritists he did
much evil in the sight of the Lord to
provoke to anger whoa much evil hey this
is God is like not pleased with this at
all so the king of Israel was a king of
Israel and he was actually taken into
captivity and it was in captivity that
his heart turned back to the Lord and he
repented you know he had this what have
I done moment you know I've spent so
much time so much of my life doing evil
he woke up he repented God restored him
back to Israel and when he got there he
tried to undo everything that he had
done and God blessed but at the same
time it was like he couldn't undo
everything the people had already gone
so far and they were so enraptured by
witchcraft and all these other things
that he had done an idol worship that he
couldn't turn the nation of Israel away
they still continued on but he had a
repentant heart and he turned away from
that and I would expect given his
repentant heart and all that he did to
turn away I would expect Manasseh is
probably one of those Kings you'll find
in heaven Lehman and that's probably
gonna be a surprise to some people yeah
they were like dude you killed me you
know or you did this but Manasseh he
turned away from all that but God does
not talk about what he did
in a pleasing light Bible also tells us
in Galatians 5:19 through 21 it says
this now the works of the flesh are
evident which are adultery fornication
uncleanness lewdness idolatry sorcery
hatred contentions jealousies outbursts
of Wrath selfish ambitions dissensions
heresies that goes on envy murders
drunkenness revelries and the like of
which I tell you beforehand okay so
before everything goes down just as I
told you in time past that those who
practice such things will not inherit
the kingdom of God so in other words
those who persist in practicing those
things not not if you've done that and
turned away but if you say you know I
don't care what God says I'm gonna do
witchcraft I'm gonna you know
participate in whatever activity I want
to you think God is saying I'm sorry
have another place for you yeah the Sura
bilious spirit yes thank God that he
does forgive people who have missed with
that stuff you know and then what
happens at the end of the book right
we're all familiar with the end of the
book we know at the end of the book
Jesus wins heaven is a great place all
right what does it say about heaven it
says but the Cowardly unbelieving
abominable murderers sexually immoral
sorcerers idolaters and all Liars shall
have their part in the lake which burns
with fire and brimstone which is the
second death mmm it also tells us in
revelation 22:15
but outside and it's talking about the
heavenly city right after all the
redeemed are safe inside the New
Jerusalem it says but outside are dogs
and sorcerers and sexually immoral and
murderers and idolaters and whoever
loves and practices a lie Wow
so very strong language but we know at
the end of the book if you're bent on
practicing those things and you'd rather
have that instead of Jesus God says
you're not gonna be in the heavenly City
he'll respect your decision yeah he will
respect your decision revelation
describes a time in the end when oh the
nations are gonna be deceived by
sorceries revelation 18 123 yep it says
for thy merchants were the great men of
the
earth for by thy sorceries were all
nations deceived so I mean it this is
what we're coming to you know that
people are just millions of people are
being deceived by sorcery and being
enchanted like you said like they're
they saw that King and he made it look
glamorous or whatever and they couldn't
turn away from it like going back to
somebody that's just passively observing
like if you're just watching these
things and it's like okay fine I'm not
going to get involved in sorcery I'm not
gonna get involved in witchcraft right
but that that in itself is just numbing
your mind to those kind of things and so
when the real sorcery like in the end of
the world the the end time people are
gonna deal with some serious deceptions
so if you can't discern a simple
deception just like a simple movie like
this and say okay I don't want anything
to do with this says witchcraft and
things that are immoral to God and well
how are you gonna do that when the real
sorcery comes out at the end of the
world and it's really a deceptive super
powers not just a cartoon anymore it's
yeah it's like if you can't pick it out
from this you are not gonna pick it out
from when when Satan really steps on the
scene yeah and let's make this personal
you know if say each of us have a friend
that we call our friend we have a
personal relationship with home world
we're both on the same page but then you
know that there's a different person who
has malicious intent against your friend
but then you decide to go to spend time
with that person anyway and get counsel
from that person how do you think your
friend would feel so how do you think
Christ feels when you're spending your
time engaging in the devil's
entertainments and all these things how
does that how do you think God feels in
that situation a subtle statement would
just be I don't want to watch it if it
if it's got things that are outside of
you know what God wants for us well I'm
thankful that Jesus is the one that has
the power we don't need to take any of
these things from the world of
witchcraft magic any of that we can go
to Jesus Jesus has all the power in the
world so if you have problems you want
to go to Jesus because he can solve all
your problems he has all the power
all the write and when he was here on
this earth you know we know that the
demons were subject to him
spirits were subject to him he cast them
out and he is the one that can help you
in your life and whatever struggle it is
it doesn't have to be magic or sorcery
can be anything
Christ provides the victory and power to
overcome and we can all be very thankful
for that
so with this show we're gonna try
something new we have a free download
that we would like to provide you and
you can use it as a personal resource
pass it off to a friend and use it in a
small group Bible study so I want you to
check the link below and you'll get this
free download about this movie on word
and what the Bible has to say about
magic and sorcery and now it's time for
our patreon post show discussion so
we're gonna end our show here if you
want to see the patreon post show
discussion you're gonna have to tune in
and become a patron so any final
thoughts on the movie onward guys don't
go see it all right well thank you for
joining us and we really appreciate all
of our supporters once again we thank
you for watching our show make sure that
you subscribe so that you'll know when
other videos come out you know hit that
hit that Bell and you'll be notified
every time a new video comes out and
well I don't think there's anything else
am I missing anything guys alright we
will see you next time thanks for
watching
[Music]